notre éditorialiste arte france eric
revel
elik merci d'être avec nous on le voir
les français qui souffrent on va en
parler longuement tout à l'heure avec le
témoignage d'un boulanger suivi d'un
petit débat les français pris à la gorge
pour payer leurs factures on a toujours
dit que emmanuel macron était le
président du pouvoir d'achat en tout cas
lui s'en défend il ya quelques chiffres
qui vont dans le même sens mais tout de
même contestations sur sur ce bilan en
tout cas sur le ressenti des français
sur le terrain alors j'ai pas si on a
dit que emmanuel macron était le
président du pouvoir d'achat en tout cas
françois hollande lui le dit a dit lui
que c'était le président des riches
surtout vous souvenez sans doute de
cette phrase qui avait fait beaucoup
parler ce qui est incontestable c'est
que dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion
qui sortent à quelque 68 jours de cette
élection présidentielle le thème du
pouvoir d'achat c'est le thème numéro un
des français devant la sécurité ou
devant la question d'ailleurs de
l'immigration donc c'est un thème
évidemment très important parce que le
pays depuis la crise sanitaire même si
le quoi qu'il en coûte à fait du bien
avec le chômage partiel payés par l'état
le pays est presque en train de tomber
dans une sorte de crise sociale il ya
des crises communautaire il ya une crise
sociale profonde dont vous avez une
question de pouvoir d'achat en france
qui récurrente des salaires qui n'ont
pas suffisamment augmenté parce que les
entreprises pendant cette crise
sanitaire qui était une crise économique
ont évidemment ralenti l'augmentation
des salaires et vous avez par dessus
tout ça vous venez de lire une inflation
qui gagnent beaucoup de terrain quand
vous avez des salaires qui n'augmentent
pas et une inflation qui rogne le
pouvoir d'achat eh bien vous d'elle vous
avez des situations sociales notamment
pour les plus modestes qui deviennent
extrêmement préoccupante et quand on
regarde juste un chiffre 1 les études je
pense à l'institut des des politiques
publiques qui a publié cette étude en
fait vous rendez compte que même si on
peut opposer une étude à une étude mais
vous rendez compte que sous emmanuel
macron sont plutôt les plus riches qui
ont accru leur pouvoir d'achat alors que
les plus modestes et les plus pauvres au
contraire vu leur pouvoir d'achat rogné
donc ça c'est une étude qui le montrent
et évidemment le président de la
république qui va être candidat qui va
rentrer dans cette élection il va devoir
avec son nouveau projet politique
économique assurer les français pour
qu'il le réalise qu'il fera quelque
chose et il encore crédible pour le
pouls leur pouvoir d'achat parce que le
pouvoir d'achat c'est une notion un peu
un peu irréel qui est pas forcément
concrètes mais c'est très concrètement
comment vous nourrissez votre famille
comment vous payer votre loyer comment
vous payer vos factures d'énergie qui
n'ont fait qu'augmenter en france
notamment alors il ya pas qu emmanuel
macron qui n'a toujours pas sa
candidature évidemment il ya les autres
en ont les voit l'oeuvre adhèrent tous
les jours faire
les oraux grand zorro
les hommes politiques justement de se
payer ce qu'ils ont pris la mesure de la
pauvreté qui est en train de s'installer
que vous
oui quand vous regardez les programmes
des principaux candidats de gauche et de
droite en france évidemment il ya des
mesures salariales qui sont proposés ci
voulait il ya deux types de mesures que
vous soyez un candidat de gauche vous
soyez un candidat de droite quand vous
êtes de gauche vous essayez d'avoir
comme marqueur l'augmentation du smic le
salaire minimum parce que par définition
votre électorat est plutôt dans cette
catégorie là même si on peut être riche
et voter à gauche donc la gauche est
plutôt augmentation du smic vous avez
des gens aujourd'hui l'état 1260 euros
d'aidés jean jean luc mélenchon anne
hidalgo qui propulse un smic à 1400 à
1500 euros ça c'est pour la vision de
gauche d'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
notamment des catégories sociales les
plus modestes à droite c'est une autre
approche à droite on appris aussi
évidemment conscience du problème du
pouvoir d'achat mais à droite on ne
parle pas forcément d'augmentation du
smic on parle de d'allègement des
charges et des cotisations ce qui
intéresse par exemple valérie pécresse
dans son programme c'est d'alléger les
charges sur la feuille de paye pour que
le salaire net augmente mais évidemment
si vous alléger les charges et moins de
recettes pour l'état et l'état qui est
déjà dans une situation compliquée de
1900 milliards d'euros de dette voilà
cette question est prise aussi c'était
ma prochaine question parce que c'est
une mesure qu'elle propose évidemment
joyeusement nos candidats à la
présidentielle eh bien comment on les
finance qu'on sait pas la compétitive
compétitivité qui en prend un coup sur
l'augmentation du smic et bien
effectivement c'est le financement qui
pose question vous avez bien sûr alors
bon lait les candidats ont chiffré un
peu la louche comme on dit leur leur
programme mais c'est vrai que ce sont
des dizaines de milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires g ou prendre un
autre exemple plus que la crise de
l'énergie est très forte en france le
prix de l'essence en vol le prix du
gasoil vous avez par exemple par line le
pen qui dit je vais mettre une tva à 5,5
sur tous les produits énergétiques
aujourd'hui je crois que sur l'une des
100 salles et à 16% alors vous dites
magnifique sauf que quand vous passez de
16% à 5 5 pour l'état
ce sont des milliards et des milliards
de recettes en moins qui ne rendent pas
et quand vous savez que la tva c'est le
premier impôt en france est un vrai
sujet est ce que maintenant les français
vont élire ou réélire leur nouveau
président de la république en leur
nouvelle présidente de la république sur
un programme sur un projet ça c'est une
question centrale parce que les projets
il y en a toujours eu les mesures
avancées pour appâter le vote elles ont
toujours été extrêmement ronflante et
puis derrière il ya forcément une très
grosse désillusion parce que le
financement il n'est pas du tout assurée
et parfois même je vais vous dire
certains candidats mettent un peu de
côté le coût de leurs mesures ce qui les
intéresse le plus c'est le symbole que
représente cette mesure pour l'électorat
politique qu'il vise pour le reste c'est
un peu après moi le déluge
suivra ça évidemment avec attention
pendant le reste de cette campagne merci
à vous eric revel éditorialistes rt
france et partant jeu